Okay, here we go!
Hey, palsies!
My name's Cody,
and I'm a Helpster.
That means a monster who helps.
And because I love, love, love
to help people so much,
I'm making these videos called...
If you know me,
you know I love to make a plan.
It's the best way to figure out
how to do something.
But guess what?
Sometimes something happens,
and you have to
change your plan. Mm-hmm.
Like today, I was supposed to go
to the park to see my favorite tree,
a cherry blossom tree.
Except I found out...
♪ Bum-bum-bum ♪
The park is closed.
Aah! I know, right?
But then I asked myself,
"Hey, Cody."
"Yes, Cody?"
"Is there another way to see
your favorite tree?"
"Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What if you
made your favorite tree?"
"You mean like
out of paper and stuff?"
"Yes, I do."
"I love that idea!"
"Thank you so much."
"Yes!"
"You're great."
"You're great too."
Ha! So, that is the new goal:
Make my favorite tree
so I can see it.
Job one: Get paper.
Mm-hmm. Job one done. Ding!
Job two: Cut the paper
into the shapes I need.
Cut, cut, cut, cut, cut, cut,
cut, cut, cut, cut!
Oh, by the way, if you do this,
make sure you get a grown-up
to help you, 'kay?
Cut, cut, cut, cut, cut,
and job two done. Ding!
And the third and final job:
Glue it all together.
♪ Hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm ♪
♪ Glue, glue, glue, glue,
glue, glue, glue ♪
Okay, looks like
all the jobs are done, mm,
because... here is my tree!
Oh, it is so beautiful
and life-like.
And you know,
if I use my imagination,
I can almost smell
the cherry blossoms.
Ahh!
You know, you can do almost
anything if you use your imagination.
You can even imagine yourself
in different places like...
Antarctica.
Whoa! Will you look at that?
Oh, hey! Hey, I'm gonna go play
with those penguins over there,
but I'll be back real soon.
And until then,
see what you can do
to help the people
and the monsters around you.
Because everyone loves
a helping hand. Bye!
Hey, wait for me!